so I think it's funny I wonder what the
probability of having two statisticians
back-to-back is this workshop but
appreciate going after your cue prepared
you all to think statistically it's
great I also want to thank the
organizers and then Simons this is great
to be here
so as Marco said I'm Joshua Snoke I work
for the RAND Corporation which is Policy
Research Institute if you're not
familiar and today I'll be talking a
little bit about some work I have on
differentially private synthetic data as
well as evaluation synthetic data in
general which will lead us into that so
before I go into that I wanted to have a
few slides just about my experience
moving into policy institution and the
conversations I've been having about
privacy with people there because it's
very different and what I'll say is that
the conversation is is really two steps
behind this room so conversations I'm
having with people are not why should we
adopt formal methods such as
differential privacy they're not what is
the privacy accuracy trade-off and how
can we optimize it
they are wait people think about this
problem so especially from someone
coming with a technical background like
statistics people are shocked that that
I studied this they they have no idea
that this is a thing this is not
everyone but this is the vast majority
and so when I look at the the drivers of
this disconnect I think a lot of it is
is a lack of context for people for this
problem and a lack of knowledge of what
solutions exist and so here are just a
few examples of things that I've I've
run into a lot in conversations so the
first one is that data sharing means
forming trusted networks and this is
certainly one way of doing it I don't
want to say that's that's a bad solution
but there's a lot more that can be done
but
for most people that's that's as far as
it goes if you have data that needs to
be shared you form a trust network where
you can dump it and one of the funny
examples I ran into was someone I was
talking to said that they were given
data which had been encrypted and what
this meant was someone sent them a file
where the identifying variable which I
think was Social Security number
someone had run a program that swapped
characters in the Social Security number
but he was able to easily figure out
they had done this deterministically and
they just walked two characters for the
whole column and yeah that was what they
were calling encryption so and then one
that I've run into a lot is is ignorant
that that any u.s. census data is
perturbed so people use for example ACS
data all the time and many people have
told me they had no idea that these
values were were perturbed in any way
and so you know I don't want to put all
the you know kind of blame on on one
side I think there is privacy illiteracy
but I think part of the issues that
we're not answering enough roving
questions I think people are not hearing
from people in this field answers to
things that they care about so for
example how do we protect complex
surveys what if my research is
evaluating an educational program that
will affect millions of kids lives what
does it mean to put noise infusion into
that and and what about causal inference
this is a huge one a ton of people at my
company work on causal inference and
it's it's kind of a non-starter at this
point so you know I think this goes back
to you know how are we how are we
addressing these concerns that they have
and if we're not addressing them then
then they won't be listening so maybe
some some practical suggestions or
takeaways that I've started to think
about is you know we don't have enough
people in this room or in this field to
facilitate all the data sharing that we
need to do we we are the experts what we
can't actually run all of it and and for
example you know
there there aren't off-the-shelf methods
for policy researchers so yesterday I
really appreciated John Freedman stock I
don't see him now but uh you know he was
saying we need automated methods or
something like that and there are many
problems that are far too complex for
that that will need tailored solutions
but at least developing for the simpler
problems ways that people can actually
do this on their own and I think that
starts with developing a privacy
literate society people where people
know how to frame the problem and what
solutions exist so for example there are
frameworks best practices in other
fields such as causal inference and meta
analysis and machine learning and even
if maybe there's a discussion about
whether people follow the best practice
has you know people in those fields are
not all the experts developing the
methodology people are using those tools
without being the experts and I think
that's a that's someone we need to get
to okay so I'll move on now to talking
about synthetic data and so first I want
to give just a little background on
synthetic data I imagine most people are
familiar with this but this is kind of
how I got into the problem so I actually
started working on some that dated for a
while before looking into differential
privacy and the idea here the general
idea as I would oppose it is that we
want to release fake values that
reproduce digital distributional aspects
of the original data and in the
statistical literature this was
originally proposed kind of out of the
multiple imputation framework by John
Rubin and and again the main idea was
you approximate the generative model
that you think could have produced
original sample and you draw new values
if you do that well and then the
synthetic data should serve the same
purposes as the original sample
so some of the common ways that people
do this in a non differentially private
way first off if you know or can
approximate a joint distributional form
there's a lot of work on Bayesian models
so Jerry writer at Duke has done
extensive work on this and they have a
lot of very good models more commonly
and a little bit more simply is to do
fully conditional conditional sequential
synthesis and this is where essentially
you you model one variable at a time and
and generate each variable one at a time
and you do this by modeling marginal and
then additionals stacked on top of each
other and you can do this using general
linear models you can do this using car
models or other nonparametric models and
those are generally more popular because
they're because of their flexibility so
again just kind of reiterating the ideas
here you know in contrast to a query
system synthetic data is focusing on the
general distributional similarity rather
than answering specific answers and I
will put aside there is you know
synthetic data that is tailored
specifically for certain people or
certain problems so that's not what I'm
talking about what I'm talking about is
general used synthetic data where you're
going to be releasing it for a variety
of reasons you don't know how the users
are going to be using it and really what
this is useful for is exploration of the
data and some in the room may disagree
with me but I think it's unlikely to be
statistically valid for making specific
inferences if your goal is to make a
general use product and you're not
tailoring it for specific things I don't
think you're going to be able to
guarantee statistic validity for
specific inferences
okay so so how do we evaluate synthetic
data so we put paper on this and this is
I think a lot of work in progress and
it's actually fairly similar to what
Christine presented yesterday which I
was encouraged to see other people
taking this approach so what we do is we
essentially evaluate distributional
similarity using a classification
approach so in other words can if we
combine the original data and the
synthetic data can we discriminate
between the two of them can we tell
which ones are real or which ones are
fake and if we're not able to do that
then the synthetic data looks like the
original data on a distributional level
so again we can understand this as a
classification problem where high
utility or high accuracy the way I'm
defining utility here it's
distributional similarity relates to a
high miss classification rate we're not
able to discriminate between the two
data sets
so how do we do that so what we use is
we we essentially combine the two days
as we stack them we add a group label
for the original data and the synthetic
data and then using some classifier we
get predicted probabilities for the
group labels and then we take the MSE of
those predicted probabilities so in this
case the the C on the bottom if your
data sets are equal sized would be 0.5
and if all of our predicted
probabilities are close to 0.5 it means
we can't discriminate very well between
the groups and so our PMS C would be
close to zero so that would be high
utility in this situation and then what
we show in our paper is that under the
null yeah where does a classifier come
from is it trained on ahead of time or
yeah it's a good question so I mean it's
it's a bit of an open question I think
you could you could do a kind of cross
validation approach I haven't tested
that but that's my intuition okay so so
essentially well okay so there's two
things so if you're using either circa
Gresham you can just specify it that way
meaning you train it on this on you you
build your live logistic regression
model from this combined data set
okay okay so I think I think there were
there were maybe multiple different
questions so so let me try to answer all
of them so so in this case right so the
simplest case is that you do say
logistic regression and you specify it
using all the variables right and so
what you're doing is you're just getting
a predicted probability of the group
membership based on all the variables in
your data set so there's no training and
testing in that case so the case where I
could imagine training testing and I
think maybe I jump to the wrong question
first is if you're did say use of
nonparametric model and then there's a
whole space right of how you know you
could define it based on all these
variables but there's a lot of ways I
can actually play out so in that case
that's what I meant but you could maybe
use the cross-validation approach where
you essentially split up the dataset do
cross-validation to try to find the best
nonparametric model that's the one I
haven't really worked on but that would
be probably my approach it harder to do
that are there other questions yes
and vanilla vanilla the data is true
that spoon is made equal to zero
whenever the DJ is in the spirit
variable is one even if this is even the
distribution is big it is exactly
similar to the observed data on all the
other variables my decision is going to
hopefully predict yeah it makes sense
I'm trying to think of a practical
situation where that would happen can
you do you have an example
so what you do every time with your
noticing they give yourself I could add
a bit to it saying this is a synthetic
data point which is that sort of the
point is that you want the synthetic
data to quote look like yeah I don't
understand why you would want to do that
examples are immediate you could just
take one pixel and make it white
every time you generate data itself it
becomes distinguished from you true
image but it looks almost like the to
limit because every other right
comparison against is an intrinsic is an
interesting one and we like I was gonna
this is just like a special case of some
sort of spurious artifact being added by
the algorithm and so you're
distinguishing it the fact that you this
is passed through an algorithm but not
whether they're distributed
well but then your distinguisher is
telling you like that's not a good way
that you know yeah I think I think maybe
I should when you're you're flipping it
right so I I want to generate synthetic
data which I can't distinguish what
you're talking about is adding something
into which it would allow me to
distinguish you might be able to
distinguish under this definition but
still have very good distinguishing is
the fact that it is passed through an
algorithm and not that is traditionally
different that's my body that's all but
really what you're doing here is you're
defining the things that interest is
being your why not to YJ and that's to
find on that yeah I know why he was
trying to use yeah it's a I think that's
work
yeah I think I mean I think there's two
things there I think for first off I
mean maybe that's not a bad thing that
you're catching that artifact right
maybe you should be catching the
artifact second off I think maybe we
should not dwell on this too long he
said we don't know what people are using
this data for and as soon as you
introduce that artifact someone's gonna
find a way to use it in a way that
you're gonna be very unhappy with maybe
you never expected whereas if you
satisfy this definition then you
wouldn't have that problem good but
let's yeah let's move on okay so so yeah
so under the null in the case that using
logistic regression we can show the
expectation of the variance for this
statistic and then we can use this to
basically rescale so if you were all
here for Gillian stock yesterday these
were the ratios she was talking about
and in this case if we do have its
intake data that's drawn from the
correct synthesizing distribution we
would expect this ratio to be one
now in the case that we want to use
something better than logistic
regression we can show through
simulation we have shown through
simulation that you can approximate this
in all pmc using resampling techniques
and they're quite simple one of them is
if you have multiple synthetic datasets
to simply compare them to each other so
because you know they came from the same
distribution you can compare them to
each other to get an estimate of the
null or if you only have one synthetic
dataset and you don't want to generate
more you can permute the group labels
and do that number of times and take the
average to get an estimate of the null
okay so moving on to differentially
private synthetic data so the motivation
behind this is it's kind of twofold so
from the synthetic data perspective
there's a very strong general modeling
framework literature that has been
developed in statistics and so I think
this is something excuse me
this is something that I think we should
we should draw on and and not discard
and not reinvent the wheel and so trying
to kind of bring that in to differential
privacy as a goal and and on the flip
side
these traditional synthetic data
approaches don't have any formal risk
attached to them
we're from more formal privacy and this
original proposal that you know because
the data is fake
this turns out to be unconvincing in a
lot of situations and I don't think I
really need to motivate it for this
crowd but here's just a simple example
in my work on synthetic data you know
this is using a typical synthetic data
approach a traditional one and the light
blue bars are this intact into the dark
blue bars of the observed data and on
these four variables we have the
histograms in there and they're
perfectly matching I think maybe
slightly different but this is this is
what you're you're outputting with
synthetic data and where's the privacy
in this case these are like on the
totals right so you know that's kind of
good that your totals are somehow
benchmarked if he would have done the
same thing within subdomains you would
have seen a lot more noise and then you
would have said you know I actually
don't think you would I mean I think
that's a fair question but I actually
don't think that you would see it that
much difference even if you look
not not with not with some of the models
that have been used okay so for this for
this approach there's there's really two
goals as I said and so the first one is
is to develop a framework in which we
can combine differential privacy on top
of the existing synthetic data models
and the second one is to relax the
assumptions on data type and boundedness
so we can work with both continuous and
categorical categorical data and not
have to make assumptions on our
continuous data about bounds so some of
the common approaches that I've seen the
differential private synthetic data
literature so there's a kind of class of
approaches that look at put your
marginals or histograms where you're
bending the data if it's continuous and
a second one is to applies noise
directly to the sufficient statistics
and then generate data based on that
both of these first two again if you're
working with continuous data they
require balance from what I've seen I'd
be certainly interested to know if there
are methods which get around that in
other ways but I haven't seen them and
then this third model that I've seen
popping up recently is to use gans or
other discriminative models and this is
a very interesting direction I actually
don't know very much about Gann so I'd
be very interested to to learn more if
there are people here work on this but
from what I've seen it requires very
expensive hyper parameter tuning and
there's some questions about actually
putting into practice
okay so to motivate a little bit more
why we want to take away the assumption
of bounds in your data this is just a
toy example so what I've done here is is
just simulated some simple multivariate
normal synthetic data and I've used two
methods first is the smooth histogram
the second is this DP Bayes which is
where you perturb the sufficient
statistics and then generate data based
on that and I've kind of done it once
with a generous bound which is two times
the standard deviation of the of the
true data because I know that and
because it's multivariate normal that's
that's about a good bound and the second
one is four times which is it's much
much wider and we'll introduce much more
noise and so maybe it's a little bit
hard to see but the dotted lines are the
larger bound right and so we're getting
a fairly different difference in our
estimated coefficients right so I'm
estimating a regression here and I'm
looking at the coefficients from the DPS
in that data versus the original
synthetic data so I'm just an absolute
difference and the way you choose your
bound is very important in terms of of
that difference and so this is just
motivation for why if you're working
with continuous data we want to to take
away that assumption because you may not
always have good prior information to
inform what those bounds should be
okay so just to reiterate we developed a
flexible method to generate synthetic
data that satisfies epsilon differential
privacy it's applicable to any
parametric's and this synthetic data
model so it can be as complex in the
models you want it to be a compiler be
hierarchical whatever as long as it has
parameterised we can make UDP we don't
have a limitation on using continuous
data or assuming bounds and this is not
unique to our approach but it can easily
be combined with the prior information
and the utility we get from maximizing
the PMC which I just talked about so
again this is focused on a general use
data set and so what we want to maximize
is this general distributional
similarity metric
so how do we make the process DP it's
pretty simple so in a traditional
synthetic data approach you would say
draw theta for your your model
parameters from posterior predictive
distribution and draw data or you would
just use the ML the estimates and draw
data based on that but instead what
we're gonna do is we're going to draw a
parameters using the exponential
mechanism which will be differentially
private and then we're going to generate
data based on those and that data will
also then be differentially private and
if we want to release one or more
synthetic datasets which is common in
this intact data literature we can just
use composition
okay so one of the keys here is it's
choosing utility or the quality function
as some call it the exponential
mechanism and if you recall we're
sampling from something like this
density and our choice right is
important for the you function so in
this case the sensitivity must be
bounded and the smaller one implies less
noise so this is where if you're working
with continuous data this is where the
bound comes into play so what we use
which is probably not a surprise is the
expectation of the PM se and and this is
first off naturally bounded between 0
and 0.25 so we can already work with
continuous data without doing any
additional work probably won't be very
good but we've already relaxed that
assumption but then we can show a
smaller bound which I'll show you that
decreases with N and because it's the
exponential mechanism right the whole
idea is that were maximizing this
utility and because we're using the p.m.
se we're maximizing this general utility
yeah I'll get to that yeah
so that it's actually the next slide so
so if we want to send the paper we
derive a bound in the case that you are
using a classification tree for the for
the function for the classifier now
there is one caveat on this that you
have to use a classification tree where
you are finding globally optimal splits
which is pretty expensive and so in that
case though your sensitivity bound is 1
over N which is pretty nice the only
problem is as I said oh I'm not getting
to that yet so just to summarize the
mechanism so given the original data set
your privacy parameter of epsilon your
synthesis model and then your called
your utility function you're going to
sample M vectors of parameters
assuming you wanted to make M synthetic
data sets and then you will generate a
data set for each of those vectors of
parameters to give you your
differentially private synthetic data
okay so just to give you a visual of
what's going on here right so we're or
sampling parameters from this
exponential mechanism so here the black
line is our MLE estimate so I think it's
0.5 and as we raise epsilon the
distribution from which we are sampling
the the parameters is shrinking around
the MLT
right and this is a fairly simple
example just for one variable so it's
much more complicated in the joint space
and it wouldn't look this nice because
you're you're maximizing to the Joint
Distribution
but this is just to give you an idea of
kind of what what the goal is here
okay so going back to what I said before
about the the cart models so one of the
issues is in the proof you have to
assume that you're finding globally
optimal trees which is computationally
unlikely for anything other than a
really small data set and so what we
wanted to look at was you know if you're
using even a reasonably sized data set
you know how much how how bad is that
how much do you violate this bound
empirically just to get a sense and so
what we found is that you you don't
violate it very often
I think it's below 5% in the worst case
and in in the average case it's like 2%
of the time you violate the bound which
is not very often but you can't never
violate the bound if you want to
guarantee differential privacy and in
fact sometimes you do violate it quite
dramatically
so here the dark circles are the ones
that violate the bound so this was just
kind of an interesting simulation that
we wanted to run to see how far off the
empirical was from from the theory
so in practice what you could do is you
could use an optimal tree if you have a
very small data set or a very good
computation but that's that's not likely
and so you can use a much weaker bound
which you get from partitioning the data
and calculating the MSE for each
partition and then averaging the PMI see
so this will be a 0.85 over m where m is
the number of partitions and you know in
practice that m could be fairly high
relative to n but it's still a much
worse bound and the one over n was
unfortunately one nice thing about this
though is that if you're doing this you
can use any classifier so you're not
restricted to cart' models anymore and I
should make one point you know the it
might seem really kind of weird that I
derived the theory for cart models I
went through four or five other models
that I tried to do first and it turned
out carts the only ones I could derive
the theory for so there's there's
potential for for more work there but in
the practical case if you use this bound
you could use any classifier and there
are probably better ones out there you
could also use something like smooth
sensitivity I haven't really looked too
much into whether this is a better
option but my sense is that it actually
would be a larger bound then the simple
partitioning would be
so as I said this is a larger bound that
we'll have to use in practice but it's
it's still useful
okay so just want to give you a little
bit of simulation results this is again
a fairly simple example but what we're
doing here is I have the two methods
that I showed before the deep eBay's in
the smooth histogram and I've I've
chosen the the nice bound for them so
this is kind of a good case for them and
we're comparing it to Cynthia generated
by the PM se mechanism and on the y axis
we have the the PMC so so this is kind
of where the PMC mechanism should do
well and we do see that it is doing
pretty well at the low values of epsilon
it's actually jumping up above the
smooth histogram but it's it's doing
pretty well and the blue at the bottom
that is if you were to do synthetic data
without any differential privacy and
you're generating from the correct model
and I know it's the correct model
because you have a question Madame so
yeah so the blue one is is if you're
tearing from the correct distribution
right so you can think of this as what
our lines should be asymptoting to as we
go out to epsilon and that is what we
see so John I hope you're happy
yeah go ahead Adam so what and here is
five thousand so one thing I guess about
I'm metric like PM se and this camp
comes up and like they began literature
also is that you could have you you
could have weird you could have like
interesting subpopulations who disappear
from the real dick in the city that are
present in the real data but absent from
the synthetic data as long as that Sub
Pop even if that's a sub population
where the classifier is like absolutely
sure that these are real data points or
vice versa absolutely sure that they're
synthetic that as long as they occupy
less than a you know in this case what
two percent fraction of the population
then they're not going to register on
your on your utility metric and I was
wondering if you gave any thought and
asked because this comes up has come up
elsewhere also if if you gave any
thought to like sort of evaluating the
classifier confidence and looking for
any issues with any any places where
there's some high confidence
distinguishing versus low confidence no
I mean that hasn't haven't looked into
that I think that's a really interesting
question I mean I guess my first thought
in response to that would be you know
those are probably the hardest groups to
protect in a privacy setting so you know
I mean in this case the privacy
guarantees is given by the epsilon right
so it's the hardest these are the
hardest things to
to keep these sort of these features of
the data that are right
supported by enough people to get
principal right so there's kind of two
things there's the there's the way I'm
setting it up which is in some ways
maybe excluding those subgroups but
there's also the the privacy question of
you know even if you weren't signing up
that way would you still be able to
preserve those groups because they're
the hardest ones to choose right so I
think it's a two-sided problem is all
I'm saying
yeah is you're getting good I just
wonder would it be helpful in that
context that may need to use
kolmogorov-smirnov talked about
yesterday way yeah I mean you're looking
at the biggest difference between the
distribution of the propensity score and
then you would find maybe exactly these
problematic cases where the yeah so I
think from a valuation standpoint that
would be that would be definitely worth
looking at I think you would run into
issues and making it difference would be
private
it's not bounded you can just slot it
into this
their thoughts
yeah well I think I'm close to time or
maybe close to the original time so just
a few thoughts looking ahead you know in
my kind of research looking at practical
differentially privates and tech data
methods they rely very heavily on priors
and modeling and so this is again you
know just kind of reiterating there's
there's a lot of work in how do we
develop good models for synthetic data
and so I think an approach that allows
us to layer TP on top of that rather
than kind of reinventing the wheel it's
a good one now they're you know most of
the issues I think with with my work so
at this point is is practical
I think Adam Rees is a really good point
but in terms of practical issues there's
there's computational issues so you know
you you get a much better sensitivity
bound if you use an optimal cart but
that's pretty infeasible and then you
know there's there's an issue that
didn't really talk about but as as your
number of parameters grow if you have a
complex model you could have a very high
number of parameters and then sampling
from that space with the exponential
mechanism becomes tricky and and that's
that is not really an area of expertise
for me and so that's where I would
definitely want to draw on other
people's expertise moving forward all
right thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah absolutely if you could say a few
words about what kind of sampling you
use do you manage to sample exactly from
this exponential mechanism or use some
sort of approximation and yeah okay so a
few answers so we used MCMC and yeah
so that I think is is a question that
still needs to be answered in terms of
the privacy guarantee I'm not really I
guess clear on that and how that how
that plays into it the the other
approximations that we do such as like
the approximation to expectation and
stuff that's fine like you could show
that that's a lower bound or the other
expectation is an upper bound I can see
your key there in the simulations
actually you know with the low values of
epsilon I think part of the reason it
jumps up so much is because I was
getting poor mixing and so I don't I
don't think I was sampling very well
from the space basically so yeah again
this is this is not an area of expertise
for me so I would I would need to learn
more does that answer all your questions
okay yeah I just wanted because you
mentioned that you know you could still
release multiple copies right but then
of course the question would be why
would you do that I mean in practice
generally the idea was you could somehow
try to get a variance estimate right but
but then in this case you would also
need to integrate again the uncertainty
back
[Music]
why were you release yeah Sam I thought
there was mostly in terms of making it
amenable to the kind of synth activated
literature you have people who are
releasing multiple synthetic data sets
as an option I I haven't really figured
out whether it's the right thing to do
or not yeah thank you an option actually
to try to estimate the uncertainty
because now the difference between the
estimates you get your different
synthetic copies actually incorporate so
I mean I think there's two things right
so you know it's it is functionally
still like you're doing a posterior
predictive where you're doing as a
sample the parameter step and then a
sample if the data step but like Adam
said it's not unbiased there's yeah
there's something should say and we will
start at 11
let's make